President Trump is expected to meet with
Chinese leader Xi Jinping at the g20
summit and Buenos Aires tonight the
president is using the summit to work on
US trade deals tonight's meeting could
be the first step towards easing trade
tensions between the US and China let's
go back to major Garrett who is
traveling with the president major good
morning again good morning again and of
course the George HW Bush will be a part
of the experience here today as world
leaders will no doubt off of their
personal condolences to President Trump
and something of a historic coincidence
on his last day here at the g20 as over
dinner President Trump will try to ease
trade tensions with the Chinese
President Gigi peeing in a fort avoid
rather an all-out trade war the historic
coincidence before becoming president
one of George HW Bush's most important
government postings and early envoy to
Communist China President Trump spent
his first full day at the g20 dodging
the two authoritarian leaders he has
tried to build bridges to would who have
recently become objects of international
skepticism and scorn mr. Trump's
distance did not stop Russian President
Vladimir Putin and Saudi Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman from enjoying a
public display of affection as the
president walked by mr. Trump canceled
planned meetings with Putin in route to
Buenos Aires citing Russia's seizure of
Ukrainian ships and sailors this week
and yet White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders issued a statement saying
special counsel Robert Muller's
investigation was undermining the
us-russian relationship the president
also had a brief off-camera encounter
with the Saudi Crown Prince their first
face-to-face since the killing of
journalist Jamal Khashoggi whose murder
has been linked to bin Salman by US
intelligence a White House official said
they quote exchanged pleasantries
earlier in the day the president and
leaders of Canada and Mexico signed a
new trade deal formerly known as NAFTA
negotiations between Canada and the US
were tense and remain in some cases
unresolved Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
urged the president to lift steel and
aluminum tariffs imposed on Canadian
imports it's been long and hard we've
taken a lot of barbs and a little abuse
and we got there it's great for all of
our countries and an even bigger trade
issue hundreds of billions of dollars in
threatened us-china tariffs on top of
those already in place tonight President
Trump and Chinese President Xi Jinping
hold a working dinner in hopes of
defusing and all-out trade war senior US
and Chinese officials here yesterday
expressed optimism that both countries
could reach some measure of progress on
trade thereby delaying future tariffs
that optimistic appraisal dana led the
dow to close nearly 200 points higher
yesterday major thank you very much